corporations are not people and when
they say stuff like Disney says that
something no no Disney isn't a thing
that can speak Disney's just a facade a
piece a paper that you tear away to see
who was it that said that yeah like if
you want to make the argument that
corporations are people then I'd love to
see some of these corporations go to
prison so true yes so when like a big
pharmaceutical company for instance is
accused of fraud we don't simply Go pass
a fine we say we are going to
incarcerate your corporation for five
years meaning it cannot operate
everybody who works there you no longer
work there come back in five years and
let's see where you're at and they go
well we couldn't do that it would be bad
for the economy well tell that to the
guy who went to prison for five years
what's he supposed to do when he gets
out sorry I don't play that if you've
got a corporation and there are people
breaking the law within it and it's
widespread and the whole company does it
shut it down or even like 30 for the
death penalty in that case too oh like
the execution of the corporations over
the company Erasure of the machine yeah
I think that if you sell a company you
guys should change the name